so first of all biomass power accounts
for around 12 of the uk's electricity
making it the country's second largest
source of renewable energy the
government says it's helped to
dramatically reduce the uk's use of coal
and is key to achieving net zero
emissions but some scientists argue that
burning wood for power is not a
sustainable solution so should we view
biomass as a clean energy source
bruce to you first of all and let me
just
forgive me if i'm
wrong correct me if i'm wrong
the theory behind biomass is that you
harvest forests sustainably then you
burn the wood but then if you also plant
new trees they will absorb roughly the
same amount of carbon that's being
released from the burning of the wood
and
its advocates would say that makes it a
clean renewable energy source what's
your take
that was the state of the science couple
decades ago today the notion that we
would cut down trees here in america put
them on a ship burning a lot of oil ship
them to the uk
burn them in
a giant power plant and assume that is
helpful for the climate
that is not where the science is today
the science says we're in code red
uh situation for humanity
and even the prime minister has his
tagline for how we solve the climate
coal cars cash and trees he's not
talking about burning trees he's talking
about planting trees which is a critical
part of what we need to do globally to
solve the climate crisis and so this is
just an outdated holdover from when we
didn't know better but but this does
involve planting trees doesn't it to
replace the carbon so
why is there a problem
well the two things and you mentioned at
the top of the hour one is that it takes
a long time for trees to grow back
um and then secondly the energy involved
in shipping them across the country
cutting them down in the first place uh
it doesn't make any science-based sense
to continue to do that when we're trying
to get to zero as fast as humanly
possible
and joycelyn the uk and the eu class
biomass as renewable and in fact
just to remind us the government does
say that biomass is a key element of
plans to to reach net zero targets what
are your thoughts on this
i mean i think i'd have to second what
bruce has said we need to really
reconsider what we mean by sustainable
and as the science has proved this isn't
really sustainable um when trees are
such an important part of our strategy
to get to net zero and i'm not a biofuel
expert but i think another important
thing we need to keep in mind is that
um kind of at the same time as a climate
crisis we have a biodiversity crisis and
planting trees just to be cut down again
does nothing for our biodiversity
nothing for natural ecosystems which are
equally as important and we can't just
keep focusing on this net zero kind of
calculation down to zero because it's
not a true
um kind of signifier of our progress
bruce you you don't think the biomass is
should be classed as a renewable source
of energy what
what technology might help you change
your mind if there was the technology to
capture the carbon released when the
wood is burnt
would that make a big difference and how
far away are we from that
so as jocelyn said we're trying to solve
several crises at the same time one is
climate and the other is the ecological
crisis
um we need trees for both both to pull
carbon out of the atmosphere and also to
make sure there is homes for
a lot of wildlife that's teetering on
the edge of extinction so again this
this makes no sense and um the the path
forward is how do we phase out biomass
now that the uk is very close to being
done with coal
the path ahead is investing in offshore
wind and solar and all the things that
are allowing the country to make great
progress on coal now to make the same
progress on phasing out biomass
you